dans l'actualité ce soir un premier
ministre face à deux conflits côté marin
pêcheur c'est peut-être la sortie de la
crise après une journée de négociations
marquées par des incidents violents
le gouvernement annonce l'accélération
des aides versées le président du comité
des pêches appel à la reprise du travail
côté réforme des retraites c'est une
journée de grèves et de manifestations
qui a commencé dès ce soir dans les
transports publics les perturbations
s'annoncent limitées notre invité
françois fillon le premier ministre
bonsoir ya tout à l'heure bertrand
delanoë sort du bois et bouscule le
parti socialiste il appelle la gauche à
renouer avec le libéralisme et affiche
ses ambitions à l'étranger silvio
berlusconi annonce annappes que les
décharges d'ordures vont être déclarée
zone militaire et protégé comme tel un
secrétaire d'état sera chargée
spécifiquement du dossier aux états unis
barack obama s'auto désignent de fête
vainqueur des primaires après son succès
dans l'orégon hillary clinton refuse de
jeter l éponge
enfin l'avenir de la télévision publique
la commission copé propose trois pistes
pour compenser le manque à gagner de la
publicité
parmi elles l'augmentation de la
redevance bonsoir et bienvenue à tous
les marins pêcheurs vont-ils mettre fin
au blocage et reprendre le travail c'est
en tout cas ce que leur demande leur
représentant le ministre de la pêche
michel barnier a annoncé aujourd'hui une
accélération du versement des aides
cette journée de négociations à paris a
également été marquée par des
affrontements
romain mais si damien louvet ce fut une
journée tendue pour michel barnier en
fin d'après-midi le ministre espère
avoir convaincu les représentants des
pêcheurs le plan pour une pêche durable
d'un montant de 310 millions
initialement pour trois ans sera mise en
oeuvre en deux années 110 millions
d'euros seront versés dès 2008 dont 40
millions pour soutenir le revenu des
pêcheurs en clair une aide pour
maintenir le prix du gazole à 40
centimes quand les marins le paieront
plus cher ils seront remboursés pour la
délégation venue à paris c'est une
satisfaction
l'état rembourse où le comité national
bcen remboursement pour arriver à 0,40
et sans cesse et que le marin dans sa
tête
gp une autre annonce faite par michel
barnier l'ensemble du plan daide a enfin
été accepté par bruxelles l'objectif des
pêcheurs semblent atteints les
responsables régionaux locaux une grotte
doivent appeler tous les bateaux de
pêche alors repartir en mer une
négociation tendue à l'intérieur et des
incidents à l'extérieur au pied du
ministère plusieurs centaines de
pêcheurs s'étaient réunis pour maintenir
la pression
résultat des jets de fusées fumigènes à
l'encontre des crs
quatre d'entre eux ont été blessés un
peu partout en france les marins sont
donc réunis ce soir ville par ville port
par port et s'apprête à donner leur
réponse après avoir suivi de très près
ces discussions exemple à la rochelle
françois privat fabien tormos le
scepticisme et la réserve de ses marins
pêcheurs rochelais accrochés aux
premières informations en provenance de
paris c'était inapplicable
et puis là maintenant ce serait
applicable 40 centimes on va voir
donc ce soit marqué sur du papier ans et
des belles paroles on attend le résultat
quoi vraiment du concret parce que
chaque coup c'est pareil on dernier
construit les belles paroles puis
quelques minutes plus tard ils
apprennent que le président du comité
national des pêches appel à la reprise
du travail
aujourd'hui sur les trois barrages qui
paralyse les dépôts de carburant de la
rochelle
les pêcheurs ont reçu le renfort des
agriculteurs à la mi journée
opération coup de poing dans un
hypermarché qui persistent à vendre du
poisson en provenance de port non
touchés par la grève
un peu plus tard une opération péage
gratuit sur le pont de l'île de ré ont
tu ces heures de négociations synonyme
pour certains marins de jour le plus
long jeu soir sur les barrages de la
rochelle
les pêcheurs attendent le retour de leur
représentant monter à paris aucune
tendance ne se dessine vraiment dans
l'hérault l'appel a été entendu ou les
pêcheurs qui bloquaient le dépôt de
carburant de frontignan près de sète ont
décidé de lever le camp et de reprendre
la mer
par vent chaud guilvinec le mouvement
s'intensifie des barrages filtrants sont
organisées et puis le port de
boulogne-sur-mer est paralysé les
pêcheurs ont organisé une vente de
poisson une vente sauvage de 600 kg de
poissons à 1 euro le kilo
pour bien comprendre la situation il
faut rappeler que l'envolée du prix du
gazole est une charge de plus pour les
pêcheurs mais leurs difficultés sont
bien antérieures les raisons profondes
d'un conflit cyril satellite fossard
c'est la bête noire des pêcheurs
français le panga vietnamiens des rives
du mékong
li déferle sur nos étals son prix 8
euros le kilo trois fois moins que le
cabillaud un poisson importé comme 85 %
de notre consommation
les marins français eux pèchent de moins
en moins en vivent leur production a
chuté de 6% alors que paradox la
consommation elle a grimpé de 40%
mis en cause par la profession les
quotas tâche imposée par bruxelles pour
préserver les ressources naturelles
depuis 25 ans le nombre de navires
diminue plus de 11000 en 1983 on en
compte plus aujourd'hui que 5232 des
navires détruits
sont des emplois en moins en 2001 près
de quarante trois mille personnes
travaillaient dans le secteur de la
pêche
elles ne sont plus que 17 mai dans ce
paysage rude pour les pêcheurs il ya
aussi le développement exponentiel de
l'aquaculture un poisson français
consommait sur 9 ans provient
aujourd'hui dans un instant on évoquera
le sujet avec le premier ministre
françois fillon qui est donc avec nous
en tout cas
pendant ces discussions rien n'arrête le
cours du pétrole le baril a dépassé
cette fois les 132 dollars dopés selon
les analystes par une chute imprévue des
réserves pétrolières américaines
autre conflit cette journée de grèves et
de manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites les syndicats protestent
contre l'allongement du temps de travail
pour tous journée organisée demain mais
qui a commencé en fait dès ce soir il ya
quelques minutes dans les transports
publics à paris le point avec christelle
bertrand et m'a dit diawara si on ne
veut pas être trop tard à la maison
ce train là il vaut mieux pas le rater
depuis 20h les horaires sont aléatoires
en fait tout le monde pense déjà à
demain
maintenant je pencherais plutôt pour
arriver à l'heure au travail j'ai pris
une rtt
j'ai quand même un point
un peu partout dans la gare des écrans
informe les voyageurs
le mouvement social va perturber la
circulation des trains jusqu'à vendredi
8h du matin hier un train sur deux voilà
voilà c'est à peu près cela il devrait y
avoir un ter sur deux deux trains sur
trois sont prévus pour les grandes
lignes et deux tgv sur trois sont
annoncés le voyageur et peluches les
horaires l'affiché même si la grève
n'est pas totale il va falloir
s'organiser
oui c'est quand on voit que dans les
heures de pointe a pas de frein accord
des trains à 6h du mat et avec une
demain dans toutes les gares le trafic
s'annonce perturbée et voyageurs eux
prévu d'attendre un peu et d'emporter de
la lecture au coeur du débat il y a le
passage de 40 à 41 ans de cotisation
pour toucher une retraite à taux plein
pour certains cet allongement n'est pas
inéluctable
alors qui dit vrai voici les arguments
des uns et des autres retraites le débat
avec yves jacques à et bernie mériaux
selon les projections démographiques
la france comptera dans sept ans près de
14 millions de retraités
un peu plus de 18 millions de
travailleurs cotiseront alors pour
financer les retraites ce qui sera
insuffisant si rien n'est fait le
déficit de la caisse de retraite
atteindra 10 milliards d'euros en 2015
dans ces conditions le passage de 40 à
41 ans de cotisation est il inévitable
absolument c'est inévitable et même ce
n'est qu'un pas vers 41 vers 42 on sait
bien les lésés mais la démographie est
là et c'est une bonne nouvelle et on vit
de plus en plus vieux et donc le
logement la durée de la vie qui va vous
savez qu'on gagne un an tous les quatre
ans va imposer aussi sans doute d'aller
travailler six mois ou un an plus
régulièrement dans les années qui
viennent donc on pourra partir plus tôt
mais on touchera moins et on pourra
rester plus longtemps et ça donnera le
droit plus important ce sera les choix
des individus
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
à 41 ans ne réglera rien pire cela
provoquera une détérioration du niveau
des pensions des retraités
car ce n'est pas parce que on demande
aux gens de cotiser plus longtemps
qu'ils peuvent travailler plus longtemps
les entreprises aujourd'hui les fonds
partir à 58,5 en moyenne si bien que
vous avez de plus en plus de personnes
qui n'ont pas de retraite à taux plein
existe-t-il des alternatives
la cour des comptes a émis l'idée d'un
élargissement de l'assiette des
cotisations aux revenus financiers
elle suggérait notamment de taxer les
revenus des stock-options qui
rapporterait gros sous
pour tous entre 3 et 4 milliards par an
on peut également imaginer une
contribution sociale généralisée
entreprises qui mettent à contribution
les profits des entreprises qui
aujourd'hui ne participe pas au
financement de la protection sociale
toute solution qui consiste à augmenter
les prélèvements obligatoires contribuer
à peser sur la compétitivité de nos
entreprises et donc à les inciter à se
délocaliser à l'étranger
donc on a on est dans un monde ouvert et
si on dont on impose plus de sargé
entreprises on va encore perdre plus
d'emplois et de compétitivité
donc je suis contre ces mesures chez la
plupart de nos voisins européens
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite est
fixé à 65 ans les britanniques ont même
prévu de relever progressivement ce
seuil
à 68 ans bonsoir françois fillon
remercier d'être avec nous ce soir
au soir de cette journée sociale très
chargés d'abord le conflit des marins
pêcheurs
pourquoi et comment ce qui n'était pas
possible hier l'est devenu aujourd'hui
et notamment y avait pas le feu vert de
la commission européenne
non ça ce qui se passe c'est que la
pêche est étranglé par l'augmentation du
prix du pétrole et comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même à l'instant cette augmentation
du prix du pétrole elle est continue
depuis plusieurs mois et aboutit elle
peut aboutir à la disparition de la
pêche française qui par ailleurs à
d'autres handicaps structurels donc il
faut les ai donc il faut l'aider j'ai
dit car pour le jt est pas possible
les grands ont négocié avec bruxelles
depuis des semaines et des semaines sur
deux choses sur un plan de
restructuration sur deux ans michel
barnier a proposé tout à l'heure qui
vise à moderniser les bateaux allaient
doté de moteurs plus performants à
réorganiser la pêche française pour
qu'elle soit capable de de tenir le choc
de la compétition
mais là avec l'augmentation aussi forte
du prix du pétrole ya un problème
d'urgence puisque vous savez que c'est
la seule profession les marins pêcheurs
qui supporte directement le prix du
gazole sur leur salaire ils sont payés à
la part et donc à beaucoup de marins
pêcheurs aujourd'hui qu'ils ont plus de
salaire du tour pouvoir même qui
installa négatif
donc on a décidé de mettre en place une
aide d'urgence à soutien social aux
revenus qui va permettre de compenser
cette différence mais environ us elle a
donné son feu vert
bruxelles a donné son feu vert sur le
plan de restructuration et sur l'aide
sociale que nous venons de mettre en
place c'est une aide d'urgence
nous la mettons en place de manière
unilatérale naturellement nous avons
informé bruxelles qui va être confronté
à la même situation progressivement dans
les autres pays andin à l'augmentation
du prix du pétrole va peser sur les
pêcheurs espagnols et va peser sur les
pêcheurs italiens et là il va reprendre
le travail ce soir j'appelle bien sûr
les pêcheurs à reprendre le travail
parce que il faut bien qu'ils voient et
je pense qu'il le constate leurs
dirigeants en tout cas le constate que
ont fait un effort considérable
on est le plus réactif possible par
rapport à cette profession qu'on ne veut
pas voir disparaître présent de la
république s'était engagé à sauver la
pêche française elle est vraiment
menacée c'est vrai pour des raisons
structurelles et pour des raisons liées
à l'augmentation du prix du gazole
il faut que cet effort de plus de 310
millions d'euros qui va être fait par
notre pays conduisant à la reprise du
travail
alors ce soir les routiers en appel à
leur tour au gouvernement pour les aider
face à la hausse des prix du carburant
ils menacent de descendre dans la rue à
leur tour est ce qu'on a pu ouvrir la
boîte de pandore non je dis d'abord il
faut pas on peut pas comparer les
routiers et les marins pêcheurs ses deux
métiers complètement différent je les ai
dit tout à l'heure les pêcheurs son pays
à la part c'est à dire qu'on déduit de
leur salaire le montant du gazole
utilisé par le bateau et en plus c'est
le métier le plus dangereux qui soit
c'est le métier dans lequel il ya le
plus de d'accidents et compris
d'accidents mortels donc et en ligne est
pour l'instant pour les régler et
routier c'est très difficile c'est
différent je dis pas que c'est pas vrai
c'est facile pour les routiers personne
aujourd'hui n'est insensible à cette
augmentation massive du prix du pétrole
mais qui n'est pas maîtrisable qui est
une augmentation qui est liée à la
diminution des ressources qui est liée à
la nécessité progressivement de changer
de mode d'énergie
les routiers ce que ce qu'ils peuvent
faire et ce que nous voulons qu'ils
fassent et qu'ils répercutent cette
hausse sur leurs prix ils doivent le
faire je dis pas que c'est facile parce
qu'il ya la concurrence parce que enfin
ils peuvent le faire plus facilement que
les pêcheurs et nous ce que nous voulons
c'est que cette augmentation du prix du
pétrole c'est normal qu'elles ne
viennent pas en diminution des salaires
les hommes et des femmes qui travaillent
déjà durement il faut qu'elle soit
répercutée sur les prix à la vente alors
sur le conflit des retraites
on voit que les perturbations ne sont
pas si importantes la mobilisation
s'annonce peut-être en demi teinte mais
on verra demain est ce que pour vous la
question est réglée
le conflit est derrière déjà bon d'abord
je suis très attentif à cela ce conflit
comme a comme à toute manifestation de
nos concitoyens simplement je fais
remarquer que cette question elle a été
tranchée en 2003 c'est la loi de 2003
que j'avais porté à l'époque devant le
parlement sauf qu'entre tiers seniors
n'ont pas retrouvé le travail ça c'est
pas tout à fait vrai mais cette fois
elle prévoit quoi elle prévoit comme
cela a été dit tout à l'heure très bien
d'augmenter progressivement la durée de
cotisation ou fur et à mesure que la
durée de vie augmente normal on peut pas
passer une partie de plus en plus
importante de sa vie à la retraite alors
même que personne n'est là pour payer
des retraites de plus en plus longue
donc le passage à 41 ans il a été acté
pas un accord qui avait été d'ailleurs
soutenu par une grande partie des
partenaires sociaux nous nous avons
décidé d'aller plus loin en augmentant
le minimum vieillesse en augmentant les
pensions de réversion qui sont très
faibles et que touche notamment les
veuves parce que sur le plus souvent les
femmes et en agissant sur l'emploi des
seniors alors c'est pas vrai de dire on
a pris l'habitude de dire le
positionnant s'est pas améliorée en
réalité ils s'améliorent tout doucement
pas assez vite mais il va surtout
s'améliorer parce que le chômage diminue
et c'est là où là la bonne nouvelle de
la baisse du chômage c'est pas seulement
une bonne nouvelle globale pour
l'économie française c'est une bonne
nouvelle aussi pour l'emploi des seniors
il va y avoir des tensions demain sur le
marché du travail et ce sera plus facile
avec les mesures d'ailleurs qu'on est en
train de prendre de permettre l'embauché
ou le maintien dans le travail des
seniors alors autre sujet du jour la
réforme des institutions on va découvrir
quelques images de la discussion à
l'assemblée il s'agit notamment me
donner un peu plus de pouvoir au
parlement ou encore de limiter à deux le
nombre de mandats consécutifs d'un
président de la république pour que
cette réforme soit adoptée la majorité a
besoin de trois cinquièmes des voix au
parlement
mende il faut qu'une partie de la gauche
la vote alors question certains au parti
socialiste se disent prêts à le faire
mais demande de nouvelles concessions
êtes vous prêt à en faire oui on peut
pas réformer la constitution
avec un camp contre un autre la
constitution c'est la loi de notre
république donc celle n'est ni de gauche
ni de droite
elle doit être consensuelle ou le plus
consensuel possible donc de nouvelles
concessions mais auquel on est prêt à
faire de à des concessions c'est à dire
des concessions est prête à discuter et
à modifier les propositions qui ont été
faites par le gouvernement
à condition toutefois que les demandes
qu'ils soient faites par la gauche ne
conduisent pas à perdre les voix d'une
autre partie du parlement et c'est ce
que j'ai essayé de négocier avec le
parti socialiste en particulier lorsque
j'ai eu l'occasion de discuter de ces
sujets avec eux vous savez que cette
réforme elle a été conçue d'abord la
commission balladur verdure où il y
avait des hommes de gauche et des hommes
de droite jack lang ben particulier mais
ensuite j'ai reçu les responsables des
partis politiques et à chaque fois on a
essayé de le faire droit à leur demande
mais sans donner la victoire un camp
contre un autre donc c'est un bruit mais
c'est un oui mais c'est à dire qu'on en
a déjà beaucoup amélioré le texte par
rapport aux demandes de la gauche
certains trouvent qu'on ne va pas assez
loin mais d'autres trouvent qu'on est en
train de remettre en cause des
équilibres de la vème république ce qui
n'est d'ailleurs pas exact c'est une
réforme qui vise essentiellement à
donner des pouvoirs supplémentaires au
parlement
et c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire de la vème république un
président de la république décide de lui
même de réduire ses pouvoirs d'encadrer
son pouvoir de nomination ou de donner
au parlement plus de maîtrise en matière
d'ordre du jour alors puisque vous
parlez du président de la république
un mot aussi du climat entre nicolas
sarkozy et vous malgré les déclarations
officielles apparemment ça ne s'arrange
pas l'elysée a convoqué une sorte de
conseil des ministre bis mais sans vous
avant de vous entendre françois fillon
le point sur ces derniers éléments avec
alix bouilhaguet philippe chasselas
vendredi dernier au pied levé françois
fillon remplacer nicolas sarkozy au
pérou des semaines que le premier
ministre n'a pas fait un seul
déplacement en france nicolas sarkozy
lui les enchaîne vous posez c'est est ce
que c'est votre
la bonne question très agacé françois
fillon car en france il fait la une
ils se détestent titre même un
hebdomadaire pendant que le premier
ministre fait le tour du monde l'elysée
se transforme en qg de campagne réunion
de certains ministres en l'absence du
premier d'entre eux l'ump la majorité
tout semble échapper à matignon roselyne
bachelot est une amie de françois fillon
depuis 35 ans le premier ministre il est
juste pour elle ce que certains
présentent comme la mise à l'écart de
françois fillon ne repose sur rien je me
demande où on va chercher ça il ya un
espèce de désir presque de meurtre pour
d'autres françois fillon est clairement
la victime d'une hyper présidence
aujourd'hui nous avons un président qui
empiète très largement sur les
prérogatives du premier ministre je
pense que françois fillon aurait pu
s'exprimer plus avec un autre président
qui subit
j'ai l'impression qu'il subit
partiellement la situation actuelle
qu'il n'est pas pleinement heureux parce
qu'ils ne donnent pas tout ce qu'ils
pourraient donner aujourd'hui on dit que
les deux hommes se voient peu en tête à
tête
elle est loin l'époque où il prenait le
temps de partager un jogging
alors d'abord je vous rassure ya pas
dans vie de meurtre mais vous êtes
ouvertement court circuiter est ce que
vous avez demandé des explications à
nicolas sarkozy on fête le 50e
anniversaire de la constitution cette
année et ça fait 50 ans que les
observateurs politiques essaie d'opposer
le président de la république est plus
ou moins tous nos moyens a conseillé les
ministres vis à l'elysée d'où de gaulle
il n'y a pas de concéder miss bee salle
alizé juhasz ministres réuni le seul
président je vais y revenir mais de
gaulle pompidou chirac giscard
mon roi mitterrand enfin je pourrais
continuer la liste comme ça et ce matin
en prenant notre petit déjeuner ensemble
tous les deux nicolas sarkozy et moi et
va perdre sans tête à tête on se
demandait si les observateurs voir ceux
qui les alimentent vivait dans le même
monde que nous la vérité c'est que ce
que nous faisons avec le président de la
république s'est changé en profondeur la
société française évoquer la démocratie
politique qui conduit la réforme de la
constitution
si ce n'est le premier ministre qui est
certain en ce moment d'essayer de
conduire une réforme de la démocratie
sociale qui est une réforme radicale qui
va changer les règles de la
représentativité françois fillon dans
les trois hommes vous at il au moins en
moins associés mais c'est ici mais c'est
une c'est une vision qui est une vision
qui n'appartient qu'aux observateurs
je pense que c'est un premier ministre
heureux c'est pas la question c'est dur
le métier que je fais est un métier
difficile parce que c'est dur de
réformer la france parce que j'ai la
charge de sujets qui qui qui touche la
vie des français qui eux mêmes ont une
vie qui est bien plus dure parfois que
que la mienne je passe à peu près la
moitié de mon temps à débattre avec le
président de la république à mettront
point il vous a causé tant de la
république
l'ailé et loose et réunion à l'instant
même quelques minutes avant que je
vienne ici à france 2 nous étions avec
le président du milan ça bien sûr que
facet un dialogue qu'on a tous les deux
c'est dans l'ajustement histoire n'est
pas françois fillon en recours non pour
la majorité dans la série classique aux
îles dans la cinquième impliquant
réalité il ne peut pas y avoir de
conflit entre le président de la
république et le premier ministre pour
une raison très simple c'est que le
président de la république est légitime
il y met en oeuvre une politique qui la
décide et le premier ministre
l'exécutent ç'a toujours été comme ça ça
et moi j'étais ministre de plusieurs
gouvernements il m'est souvent arrivé
d'aller voir le président de la
république
en dix ans le premier ministre
simplement la différence peut-être dans
le passé c'est que ça se faisait en
catimini alors qu'aujourd'hui avec
nicolas sarkozy les les fenêtres les
portes l'elysée sont grandes ouvertes
merci françois fillon d'avoir accepté
notre invitation à l'étranger d'abord
silvio berlusconi qui a enfilé les
habits de monsieur propre pour tenter
d'apaiser les napolitains qui vivent
vous le savez au milieu des ordures
depuis longtemps à l'issue du conseil
des ministres organisé sur place ils
annoncent que les décharges vont être
déclarée zone militaire
et protégé comme tel sur place à naples
philippe visseyrias karine guillaume des
sacs poubelles dans les rues de naples
mais cette fois ci pour manifester
bravant la pluie ils sont quelques
centaines venus d'un quartier
périphérique de la ville
s'opposant à l'ouverture d'une décharge
près de chez eux nous ne manifestons pas
contre berlusconi
nous essayons de le convaincre de ne pas
faire cette décharge il est notre ultime
espoir quelques centaines de mètres plus
loin
la place de la préfecture est une zone
sous haute protection c'est là que
silvio berlusconi le visage grave tient
son premier conseil des ministres comme
il l'avait promis pendant la campagne
électorale
au bout de quatre heures de réunion ils
annoncent ses premières mesures de
nouvelles décharges seront créés et
protégés par l'armée
ici les sites identifiés pour accueillir
les déchets seront déclarés et c'est
important zone d'intérêt stratégique
national concrètement et des zones
militaires blindés canons et milita pour
accueillir le nouveau chef du
gouvernement
naples a fait un brin de toilette dans
certains quartiers où s'entassent encore
plusieurs tonnes de détritus l'arrivée
des éboueurs est un événement rare que
l'on contemple comme au spectacle il
faut qu'une personne importante viennent
pour qu'ils nettoient sinon on reste
dans les ordures symbole de l'espoir
placé dans la présence du chef du
gouvernement
cette affiche géante qui proclame
berlusconi sanctifié tout de suite s'est
montré ferme sur la crise des déchets
silvio berlusconi a également annoncé un
durcissement de la législation sur un
autre dossier celui de l'immigration
désormais l'immigration clandestine en
italie devient un délit puni d'une peine
de prison
en revanche l'idée de repousser au large
les navires de clandestins dont on avait
évoqué l'idée ici même un été abandonnée
direction la birmanie maintenant qui
reste très largement verrouillé près de
trois semaines après le passage du
cyclone
l'une de nos équipes est entré
clandestinement les images que vous
allez découvrir permettre de mieux
mesurer à quel point la population reste
délaissé abandonné par la dictature au
pouvoir alors même que des milliers de
tonnes
elles ont été livrées voici le récit de
ce périple dans une birmanie interdite
arnauld miguet mathias second le sud de
la birmanie dévastée difficile d'en
rendre compte sur place quand on est
journaliste clandestinement nous prenons
la route
mais très vite ce barrage militaire nous
empêche d'aller cloud le régime a
verrouillé l'accès au delta là où le
cyclone a été le plus meurtrier interdit
aux occidentaux quel qu'il soit même
humanitaire malgré les contrôles après
deux heures de voiture nous parvenons à
ce village il y avait ici 400 habitants
50 ont péri dans la catastrophe
ici on manque de plus l'aide humanitaire
ces petits moineaux n'ont jamais vu la
couleur un peu d'argent un peu de riz
ils vont les chercher chez ceux qui en
ont
ceux là ont tout perdu un parent une
maison depuis plus de deux semaines ils
ont trouvé refuge dans ce monastère
les gens n'ont pu rien n'y a plus de
culture
les pêcheurs n'ont plus de bateaux c'est
pour ça qu'on doit s'entraider
derrière ce grand sourire la tente du
net qui arrivent au compte gouttes
ici un riche entrepreneur finance une
distribution on estime à plus de 2
millions le nombre de gisements dans le
besoin et parce qu'il n'y en a pas pour
tout le monde
on tire au sort sur ces petites feuilles
de papier celui là n'aura qu'un savant
et de moments sous l'oeil du général
tâches ou est réticent à toute
intervention extérieure
les plus chanceux repartent avec une
portion de toute la famille regardez on
distribue un sachet de nouilles du savon
et ça c'est ce qu'il plus cher du riz
mais comme on n'a pas assez pour tout le
monde on fait une sorte de loterie pour
aller plus loin pas d'autre choix que le
bateau beaucoup de zones restent
inaccessibles par la terre
très vite on nous fait signe de nous
cacher
dans ce delta on croise décidément plus
de militaires et humanitaires
pourtant dans ces villages de pêcheurs
plus grand chose tient debout dans ce
temple
seule la statue du bouddha est
miraculeusement restée intacte si le
discours officiel des généraux évoque
déjà la reconstruction ses habitants à
eux attendre simplement de manger on a
rien à manger on est content quand on a
un repas par jour
tout ce qu'on fait est payée de
reconstruire à rangoun l'ancienne
capitale birmane pendant ce temps les
petits vendeurs de rue proposé dvd de la
catastrophe pour un euro le meilleur du
cyclone tout en images en revanche
trouver des voix dissonante dans ce
régime dictatorial est pure à
rendez-vous nous est donnée dans un taxi
car ici on craint d'être vu en public
s'exprimer à visage découvert vous
conduit généralement en prison ces deux
députés d'une opposition muselée ont
déjà donné pendant dix huit et quinze
ans nos soi disant leaders
les militaires de la junte ils ne sont
même pas allés sur place pour se rendre
compte des dégâts alors que le monde
entier la communauté internationale
propose de venir à notre secours vous
savez nos chefs militaires ils ne
s'intéressent vraiment qu'à eux mêmes
trois semaines après le passage du
cyclone la junte birmane s'est
finalement résigné a décrété trois jours
de deuil national et laisser
s'entrouvrir un peu plus la porte à
l'aide humanitaire internationale
le bilan rappelons le est de 80 à 130
mille morts et sans doute deux millions
de sans abri en chine une miraculée de
102 ans cette femme a été retrouvée
vivante hier après huit jours bloqués
sous les décombres
transportée à l'hôpital elle souffre de
fractures aux jambes mais elle est
parfaitement consciente et puis beaucoup
plus anecdotique mais très important aux
yeux des chinois la plus grande réserve
de pandas un impact trop souffert du
séisme la plus grande réserve au monde
deux animaux seulement ont disparu les
autres ont été privés de nourriture
pendant des jours mais tout va bien de
ce côté là aux etats unis une victoire
partout hier soir dans les nouvelles
primaires démocrates c'est tout bénéfice
en fait pour barack obama qui ne devrait
plus être rejoint et qui se comporte
déjà comme si le combat était terminé
il a rendu hommage à hillary clinton en
parlant d'elle au passé alain de
chalvron ariel monange
patte de velours et toutes griffes
dehors barack obama à changer de braquet
hier fini la campagne des primaires cap
sur l'élection du 4 novembre et pour
cela un impératif se réconcilier avec
l'adversaire d'hier
hillary clinton pas de vélo hillary
clinton à briser des mythes ont fusé
barrières et changer l'amérique dans
laquelle mes filles et vos filles vont
grandir et on lui en est reconnaissant
john les griffes désormais sont réservés
à john mccain avec une claire stratégie
imposée l'équation mccain égale bouche
ou mieux mccain
oui c'est pire que bush cette année la
course des primaires chez les
républicains
c'était à qui serait le plus bushiste
des bush is etc mccain qui a gagné le
candidat républicain n'est pas en reste
du haut de ses 71 ans il accuse sont
désormais unique adversaire d'angélisme
chacun voulant rencontrer sans condition
les dirigeants iraniens
obama montre la profondeur de son
inexpérience et de son manque de
jugement
tiens tiens on croirait entendre hillary
clinton ou plutôt l'ancien hillary la
question aujourd'hui de trouver une
sortie pour l'ex première dame
s'ils veulent gagner en novembre les
démocrates doivent refaire leurs unités
et réparer les dégâts d'une campagne des
primaires trop longue et trop sanglante
en bref encore à l'étranger un accord
pour la sortie de crise au liban à doha
première conséquence élection
présidentielle du chef des armées michel
sleiman se tiendra dimanche après avoir
été reporté une vingtaine de fois retour
sur une image celle du petit mohamed al
doura tué au cours d'une fusillade à
gaza 7 et en septembre 2000 la scène
avait été filmée par france 2 accusés de
manipulation la chaîne avait porté
plainte pour diffamation et obtenu gain
de cause en première instance
aujourd'hui la cour d'appel de paris a
reconnu la déformation mais elle a
accordé le bénéfice de la bonne foi à
l'auteur de ces propos diffamatoires
france 2 a décidé de se pourvoir en
cassation un coup important porté à
letea le numéro un présumé de
l'organisation terroriste a été arrêté
hier soir en france à bordeaux sur place
francis mazoyer bernard bonne
aulas des slogans à la gloire de théa
dans une cohue indescriptible la police
reconduit des quatre indépendantiste
basque à leur appartement pour une
perquisition
javier lopez peña chef politique présumé
de l'organisation est solidement encadré
entrer encore plus mouvementée de l'un
de ses complices la police judiciaire
française et la guardia civil espagnole
ont procédé aux arrestations au deuxième
étage de cet immeuble vers 23h30 hier
soir des habitants n'ont appris la
nouvelle que ce matin en fait la police
a arrêté le numéro un de tes seins et ce
bonhomme habité à côté de chez moi
ce casque attaché dans ce groupe
d'indépendantistes une femme
ainhoa août ça et à soupçonner d'être la
porte-parole des conférences de presse
clandestine et bien sûr ravir lopez peña
dit thierry chef politique présumé
depuis 2006 cette année là il aurait
participé à l'élaboration d'un cessez le
feu permanent avec le gouvernement de
zapatero il aurait ensuite provoqué la
rupture de la trêve en ordonnant
l'attentât meurtrier de l'aéroport de
madrid
on revient la politique maintenant avec
le pavé dans la mare de bertrand delanoë
le maire de paris sort du bois dans un
livre publié cette semaine il affiche
ses ambitions mais surtout il appelle le
parti socialiste à devenir libéral
j'évite imbert olivier pontus bertrand
delanoë aime la liberté et le chemin
qu'il emprunte aujourd'hui est inédit au
ps son livre bien nommé de l'audace fait
trembler le vieux vocabulaire socialiste
je suis libéral écrit le maire de paris
le libéralisme est d'abord une
philosophie politique de la liberté à
gauche
nous sommes les défenseurs des libertés
y compris dans le domaine économique
une manière d'être de notre temps d'être
gestionnaire met au service de la
société et de la création d'emplois donc
moi je crois même que cette douche
tout est question de définition c'est le
libéralisme sauvage qui est vraiment
dangereux disent les amis du maire de
paris pour d'autres
le libéralisme tout court est nocif bref
le ps s'offre un nouveau débat ce combat
pour les libertés individuelles pour les
libertés collectives
c'est une idée qu'on n'aurait pas dû
peut-être nous la gauche mais c'est la
droite s'accaparer être aujourd'hui
libéral me paraît être un contresens par
rapport à ce qui se passe autour de nous
sur son avenir au ps - d'audace bertrand
delanoë prend son temps pas encore de
candidatures déclarées mais une petite
pique à l'endroit de ségolène royal et
sa démocratie participative
on ne peut pas se contenter de
recueillir les avis il faut donner le
sien
le livre est dédié à lionel chaude et
daniel comprenez lionel jospin claude
estier daniel vaillant on ne sait pas
encore si lionel jospin est devenu lui
aussi libéral au sens où l'entend son
ami la justice en bref vous vous
souvenez sans doute de l' incendie de
l'assemblée de corse qui avait provoqué
l'indignation générale c'était en
janvier dernier eh bien les trois
prévenus jugés aujourd'hui à ajaccio ont
été relaxés il s'agit de membres d'un
mouvement nationaliste et cette décision
a été accueillie par les
applaudissements de 150 à 200 militants
réunis à l'extérieur du palais à paris
c'était l'heure du réquisitoire dans la
sphère des hormones de croissance
contaminées
des peines d'emprisonnement avec sursis
de quatre ans au maximum ont été
demandés contre les deux principaux
prévenus
à ce jour rappelons le 114 personnes
sont mortes 800 autres risquent toujours
de contracter la maladie de creutzfeldt
jakob
le jugement est mis en délibéré à la fin
du mois image signée alexis fischer
l'avenir de la télévision publique
maintenant vous le savez la publicité
doit être supprimée dès l'an prochain au
moins partiellement
et bien après des semaines de débats la
commission copé propose trois pistes
pour compenser le manque à gagner
parmi elles l'augmentation de la
redevance daniel wolfromm patrice
brugère trois pistes pour compenser 800
millions à un milliard d'euros perdus
par le service public avec la
suppression de la publicité l'une
privilégie une augmentation de la
redevance élargi aux propriétaires
d'ordinateurs ou de résidences
secondaires mais ce scénario n'a pas
trop la faveur de jean françois copé
je suis pas être favorable à
l'augmentation de la redevance mais
plutôt à être favorables à taxe sur les
fournisseurs d'accès internet
deuxième hypothèse donc d'une taxe de 0
5% sur le chiffre d'affaires
considérable de la téléphonie ou
d'internet
mais il y a une troisième piste possible
ou plutôt une troisième taxe sur
l'électronique grand public à savoir le
poste de télé de tout un chacun
mais tout ceci ne fait pas l'unanimité y
compris au sein de la commission où les
parlementaires de gauche commencent à se
faire entendre
prochaine réunion prévue les programmes
et le management de france télévisions
pour un rapport définitif le 25 juin
prochain les sciences avec un projet qui
semble complètement fou un parachutiste
battante et une chute libre de l'espace
40 km d'altitude
objectif entre autres être le premier
homme à franchir le mur du son nicolas
chateauneuf avec notre bureau à
marseille un météore jaune qui fend
l'air à toute vitesse depuis 20 ans
michel fournier ne pense qu'à cela
une chute libre de 40 km d'altitude
qu'il tentera dans les prochains jours
au canada
pour y arriver cet ancien para a dû
s'entraîner encore et encore et vendre
une partie de ses biens car le matériel
ça coûte cher et notamment sa
combinaison pressurisée alors pendant la
descente mais bras seront le long de mon
corps comme ceci quand je reviendrai à
plat ça veut dire que je ne serai plus
pratiquement plus près sionisés trois
épaisseurs conçu pour le protéger du
manque d'oxygène dans les hautes couches
de l'atmosphère pour résister à une
vitesse de pointe de 1500 km heure due à
l'absence d'air et à la température
extrême deux mois sans 15 degrés le jour
j michel fournier prendra place dans une
nacelle pressurisée comme celle-ci
accroché un ballon rempli d'hélium
il gagnera un lentement de l'attitude
croisera celle des avions traversera la
couche d'ozone à 40 km d'altitude la
cabine s'ouvre michel fournier saut dans
le vide avec un petit parachute pour le
stabiliser
suivent 7 minutes 30 secondes de pur
annalynne dans ma tête je vous dirai pas
le nombre de fois que j'ai sauté déjà
chez incalculables avant de quitter la
nacelle je serai là où je pense que j'ai
quand même pendant cinq minutes pour
remplir mes yeux de cette belle rondeur
de la faire le précédent record non
officiel date de 1960 avec l'américain
joe kittinger qui avait sauté de 32
mille mètres d'altitude
il y a cinq ans un défaut du ballon
avait forcé michel fournier a renoncé
cette fois tout est prêt une aventure
qui permettra peut-être d'améliorer les
techniques de sauvetage d'astronautes en
perdition à cannes l'image de la soirée
c'est la montée des marches de madonna
qui présente un documentaire sur le
malawi où elle adopté un enfant montée
des marches aussi pour les ch'tis dany
boon kad merad line renaud et les autres
étaient également à la fête ce soir le
film du jour c'est une curiosité il est
signé emir kusturica un documentaire sur
la vie du footballeur diego maradona
emmanuel lambert michael cariou sur
place à cannes
on pensait avoir tout vu à cannes mais
ça c'est une première
maradona un dieu du football qui jongle
avec un autre géant du cinéma cette fois
emir kusturica pour ce documentaire le
réalisateur bosniaque s'en est vu deux
ans de tournage et parfois sans raison
diego qui fuient la caméra soit qu'une
série de photos ce taux de tabriz
cette fois en conférence de presse il
n'a pas de rides et les journalistes
mais pourquoi at il accepté un
documentaire sur sa vie lui qui a été
traîné dans la boue dans des livres et
des reportages
personne à part emir kusturica elle n'a
réussi à le percer à jour
il concerne l'école et à raconter toute
ma vie mais bon moment les moments les
plus durs
le passé le présent acte toile je vais
vous compreniez que ce qu'ils ont fait
avec lequel coule à 6h et colin
colossaux étaient 86 maradona gagne la
coupe du monde mais c'est ce but en
quarts de finale qui restera à tout
jamais non seulement c'est l'un des plus
beaux de l'histoire du football mais
c'est aussi une vengeance contre
l'angleterre suite à la guerre des
malouines après il ya la déchéance
diego a jonglé avec la drogue avec la
mort
au départ il m'a demandé quel
footballeur aurait j'étais sans la coke
notre stand moi je lui ai répondu et je
sais pas dans le film
mais qu'est ce que tu aurais pu faire de
bruce bataille au couteau aujourd'hui
ses passements de jambes maradona
l'effet sur un autre terrain celui de la
politique
même sans ballon il n'a qu'un but de
faire gagner le peuple avant de refermer
ce journal je vous en rappelle l'un des
principaux titres c'est peut-être la
sortie de la crise de la pêche le
gouvernement après une journée de
négociations annonce l'accélération du
versement des aides des assemblées
générales sont organisées dans chaque
fort pour décider d'une éventuelle fin
de conflit sur ce plateau tout à l'heure
le premier ministre françois fillon a
appelé les pêcheurs à reprendre le
travail et indiqué que bruxelles avait
été informé du versement de ces aides
d'urgence c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de l'avoir suivi tout de suite la
météo laurent romejko 20h50 un téléfilm
inédit le nouveau monde
à demain
wahou